[Music]
it's not
I hear nobody said it was gonna be this
time so we are here right now it's
Godzilla or about to go off the top and
Asia is so excited right now
have you ever a sip line before no I've
never decline I'm slightly nervous but I
also don't want to let my fear hold me
back I'm just here and I'm gonna do it I
might black out but that's okay I had no
idea that it looks like they're like
literally your life and then they like
open the gates McGrath and then you go
oh that's a little bit terrifying to me
are you ready for this yeah let's do it
[Music]
I'm gonna be covering the whole time
when I was little and I swam in the pool
I would go to the very surface and
pretend like I was flying and I feel
like that's what this is gonna be like
now but in real
it's gonna be all my childhood dreams
come true we're just laid out oh my god
oh my god I wasn't scared like ten
seconds ago for sure strapped into this
thing right
[Music]
my job okay I'm just gonna have real
tough
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't even I can't feel my face oh it
was like the closest I've ever felt to
flying like Superman he's like when I
was a kid in the pool like that's what
it felt like but real life I hate that I
was so scared because it's so much fun
part of the end of the word yeah that
honestly like I feel like I'm about to
drop every single time but I'm so glad I
didn't let my fears get the best of me I
could do this all day honestly and I'm
someone that has a fear of depth or
height or whatever you want to call it
like looking down from very high point
scares the [ __ ] out of me and I love
this like I have to now zipline
throughout my wire go into the car yeah
I'm ready to go again let's do it
[Music]
[Music]